being a prostitute because I was told
that I have an ATM machine down here and
I can always make money no matter what
so as long as I have a vagina I can make
money wherever I but wherever I go
alright meanie yes Mimi where'd you grow
up where you from I'm from Harbor City
California done by Long Beach yes and
tell me about your childhood did both
your parents YUM
no I had my mom my dad was on drugs
so he was out of the picture yeah so
he's out the picture I will see him
every time from time to time in Long
Beach and what the child like um my
childhood I was I'm an only child I have
no brothers and no sisters I grew up by
myself um my mom worked two jobs just to
raise me she got married to my
stepfather and my stepfather used to
molest me every day from the age of five
to eight my mom would go to work and he
would bring home we would call his
friends and they would come over and
they were party during the daytime while
my mom was at work I remember there was
a plate of white stuff in green stuff up
mother couch and he used to pull it out
when my mom used to go to work and I
didn't know what it was at the time
because I was only five years old kind
of find out it was cocaine and we so he
would get high and after he would get
high with his friends of friends with me
and he would call me in his room and
said weena come in and meet me come here
and I used to go in the room with him
and he'd sit down in front of the bed
watch the TV he would grab me and pull
me up on the bed and he would molest me
everyday um and I had to wipe myself
before my mom came home because it would
bleed down there and um so she wouldn't
find out and he would give me stuff so
that I wouldn't tell her this was going
on from the age five to eight everyday
until one day my mom came home and she
asked me if my stepdad was molesting me
and I was so scared I told her yeah my
mom blacked out she wanted to she had
PTSD was one for rehab because she
couldn't focus
I was sent to a foster home from being
told that she have yes she had a
reaction yeah I had to go to court and
the judge asking who the guy was and I
had to point him out and stuff like that
you know so he went to prison
um so he's registered as a sex offender
now um while I was getting raped
everyday molested he tore something on
the inside of me to where I I was told I
couldn't have kids you know but you know
there's God made a miracle for me to
have children ask for kidnappers
yeah so and then after that I was told
that I might get in trouble if I say
anything else to anybody so I got
molested again by my other mom's husband
um I was
he got me high I was 21 years old he got
me high and all other members that I was
pregnant I think I couldn't I didn't
know who I was pregnant by you know
everyone actually praying mine I had no
idea until after I had my baby when I
had my baby Children's Services got in
the in the you know got him to my life
because I was using drugs with my son
and when they did a DNA test and they
found out who I was pregnant by was by
my my other stepfather so I have a son
that 17 years old that's my my my mom's
ex-husband and my mom was thinking that
man here was having sex that I was the
one that was trying to turn him on
because this is the second time it
happened and it wasn't my fault so I
have a son by my stepfather know my
son's in a foster home
um he just turned 17 a couple of days
ago um I talked to him from time to time
and he always asked me who was daddy
years and I I just found out about a
month ago so today today you're yes I'm
on 17 series living in a tent
I'm homeless how do you dress oh crap
smoke crack how long you been using
crack since 1998 off and on I've used
crack so that I can get out of self
reality and it covers up my pain you
know because I've been through a lot
since I've been little I also when I was
a child got my head cracked open busted
open when I was little and I assumed the
services counted to my life so I've been
back and forth in and out of foster
homes and stuff like that you know oh
yeah well I was I was told I was jumping
on the bed and and I fell off the bed
but somebody hit me in my head and
cracked my head open and never the
reason why I got my head cracked the
ones because I told on my stepfather and
they were trying to get revenge I was
trying to kill me because I had had him
sent to prison so I got I was taken out
of the home to be putting a foster home
due to abuse child abuse so so after you
had your your son you what after I had
my son I started using again because
they my son was taken from me and I
didn't know who the father was
until recently um all my kids have been
taken from me basically because of me
using drugs me getting abused my mom
really not being there for me my mom's
always into her boyfriends that rather
being into me I have I'm an only child
so I didn't understand why my mom didn't
really want to be around me and she
blamed me for her men molesting me so I
started using I saw use dope in your
living industries yes I'm living on
streets now oh but back then you were to
us yes I've already do it for money then
prostituting I had a pimp and I had
three wife in-laws and my pimp would
take me from state to state and make
money I would have to bring home three
thousand dollars a night especially in
San Francisco and if I didn't bring home
three thousand dollars a night then I
couldn't come in the house or I would
get beat if I had less than three
thousand so my life has been based on
prostituting and getting the last thing
I'm getting my kids taken away from me
recently I almost got me almost got
murdered
my ex-boyfriend was on spikes and he was
smoking the synthetic weed and he
hallucinate it and started stabbing
stabbing 17 times and shot him twice in
my head the same day so I've been in a
hospital for three months but I still
have two bullets in my head today I have
complications he's in prison now
um this happened to Mississippi so I
started using what Mississippi the
Mississippi oh my god last year so I
started using drugs again you know
because I'm trying to take the pain away
I don't understand why I am I the one
that's being hurt all the time why do
these people want to kill me what's
what's wrong something's wrong with me I
feel something's wrong with me so I
turned the drugs on at home how are you
supporting yourself today um I Panhandle
I have a sign and I stand on the freeway
on the off-ramp it's very dangerous
yeah and I ask people for money I've
done did you know some things out here
that I don't like that I know that I'm
used to doing as far as having sex for
money and stuff like that but I
Panhandle now with the sign
on the how much will you make that
headway um it depends on the people I
know in Atlanta Georgia I was making
like eighty dollars a day but down here
in Skid Row is you don't make that much
it's probably about twenty dollars a day
you know but I have to support my habit
and I have to eat so that's how I make
my money so do you have any family that
you saw in contact with well um I just
got a contact with my mom not too long a
couple days ago and she really didn't
care that I was down here oh so no not
really it's just me by myself how do you
feel this living this street life has
changed you all these years
oh it made me it made me strong you know
I've been through a lot down here I've
seen a lot down here and um I know that
if I could survive these streets I could
survive anything
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you at all your uses we're gonna
prostitute
this life the worst thing that happened
me is being a prostitute because I was
told that I have an ATM machine down
here and I can always make money no
matter what so as long as I have a
vagina I can make money wherever I but
wherever I go
does your pimp - told you that yes yeah
I lived I've been living a hard life
it's hard now I still prostitute I'm
kind of time you do today yes because
the money is fast you know rather than
panhandling and I'm making a little bit
more money to prostituting them holding
a sign right you didn't arrest it for
anything
yes prostitution prostitution yeah and
I'll paraphernalia but most of the
prostitution what do you wish would have
been different about your childhood
maybe that might have helped you I wish
that I had my dad in my life and my mom
together in the same household I wish I
could could live to have had a white
picket fence in the White House and you
know and just went to college you know I
wish I had some of the like some of the
lives these collars piers had but I
didn't have it that way alright well
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you and good luck with everything
thank you very much
you